What I want to do in this video
is try to understand how
two proteins can interact with
each other in conjunction with
ATP to actually produce
mechanical motion.
And the reason why I want to
do this-- one, it occurs
outside of muscle cells as well,
but this is really going
to be the first video on really
how muscles work.
And then we'll talk about how
nerves actually stimulate
muscles to work.
So it'll all build up
from this video.
So what I've done here is I've
copy and pasted two images of
proteins from Wikipedia.
This is myosin.
It's actually myosin II because
you actually have two
strands of the myosin protein.
They're interwound around each
other so you can see it's this
very complex looking protein or
enzyme, however you want to
talk about it.
I'll tell you why it's called
an enzyme-- because it
actually helps react ATP into
ADP and phosphate groups.
So that's why it's
called an ATPase.
It's a subclass of the
ATPase enzymes.
This right here is actin.
What we're going to see in
this video is how myosin
essentially uses the ATP to
essentially crawl along.
You can almost view it as an
actin rope and that's what
creates mechanical energy.
So let me draw it.
I'll actually draw it on
this actin right here.
So let's say we have one
of these myosin heads.
So when I say a myosin head,
this is one of the myosin
heads right here and then it's
connected, it's interwound,
it's woven around.
This is the other one and it
winds around that way.
Now let's just say we're
just dealing with one
of the myosin heads.
Let's say it's in
this position.
Let me see how well
I can draw it.
Let's say it starts off in a
position that looks like that
and then this is kind of the
tail part that connects to
some other structural and we'll
talk about that in more
detail, but this is my myosin
head right there in its
starting position, not
doing anything.
Now, ATP can come along and bond
to this myosin head, this
enzyme, this protein,
this ATPase enzyme.
So let me draw some ATP.
So ATP comes along and bonds
to this guy right here.
Let's say that's the-- and it's
not going to be this big
relative to the protein,
but this is just to
give you the idea.
So soon as the ATP binds to its
appropriate site on this
enzyme or protein, the enzyme,
it detaches from the actin.
So let me write this down.
So one, ATP binds to myosin
head and as soon as that
happens, that causes the myosin
to release actin.
So that's step one.
So I start it off with this guy
just touching the actin,
the ATP comes, and
it gets released.
So in the next step-- so after
that step, it's going to look
something like this--
and I want to draw
it in the same place.
After the next step,
it's going to look
something like this.
It will have released.
So now it looks something like
that and you have the ATP
attached to it still.
I know it might be a little
bit convoluted when I keep
writing over the same thing,
but you have the
ATP attached to it.
Now the next step-- the ATP
hydrolizes, the phosphate gets
pulled off of it.
This is an ATPase enzyme.
That's what it does.
Let me write that down.
And what that does, that
releases the energy to cock
this myosin protein into kind
of a high energy state.
So let me do step two.
This thing-- it gets
hydrolized.
It releases energy.
We know that ATP is the energy
currency of biological
systems. So it releases
energy.
I'm drawing it as a little spark
or explosion, but you
can really imagine it's changing
the conformation of--
it kind of spring-loads this
protein right here to go into
a state so it's ready to
crawl along the myosin.
So in step two-- plus energy,
energy and then this-- you can
say it cocks the myosin
protein or
enzyme to high energy.
You can imagine it winds the
spring, or loads the spring.
And conformation for proteins
just mean shape.
So step two-- what happens is
the phosphate group gets--
they're still attached, but
it gets detached from
the rest of the ATP.
So that becomes ADP and that
energy changes the
conformation so that this
protein now goes into a
position that looks like this.
So this is where we end up
at the end of step two.
Let me make sure
I do it right.
So at the end of step
two, it might look
something like this.
So the end of step two,
the protein looks
something like this.
This is in its cocked
position.
It has a lot of energy
right now.
It's wound up in
this position.
You still have your ADP.
You still have your-- that's
your adenosine and let's say
you have your two phosphate
groups on the ADP and you
still have one phosphate
group right there.
Now, when that phosphate group
releases-- so let me write
this as step three.
Remember, when we started, we
were just sitting here.
The ATP binds on step one--
actually, it does definitely
bind, at the end of step one,
that causes the myosin protein
to get released.
Then after step one, we
naturally have step two.
The ATP hydrolyzes into
ADP phosphate.
That releases energy and that
allows the myosin protein to
get cocked into this high energy
position and kind of
attach, you can think of
it, to the next rung
of our actin filament.
Now we're in a high
energy state.
In step three, the phosphate
releases.
The phosphate is released from
myosin in step three.
That's step three right there.
That's a phosphate group
being released.
And what this does is, this
releases that energy of that
cocked position and it causes
this myosin protein
to push on the actin.
This is the power stroke, if
you imagine in an engine.
This is what's causing the
mechanical movement.
So when the phosphate group is
actually released-- remember,
the original release
is when you take
ATP to ADP in a phosphate.
That put it in this
spring-loaded position.
When the phosphate releases it,
this releases the spring.
And what that does is it pushes
on the actin filament.
So you could view this
as the power stroke.
We're actually creating
mechanical energy.
So depending on which one you
want to view as fixed-- if you
view the actin as fixed,
whatever myosin is attached to
it would move to the left.
If you imagine the myosin being
fixed, the actin and
whatever it's attached to
would move to the right,
either way.
But this is where
we fundamentally
get the muscle action.
And then step four-- you
have the ADP released.
And then we're exactly where
we were before we did step
one, except we're just one rung
further to the left on
the actin molecule.
So to me, this is
pretty amazing.
We actually are seeing how ATP
energy can be used to-- we're
going from chemical energy
or bond energy in ATP to
mechanical energy.
For me, that's amazing because
when I first learned about
ATP-- people say, you use ATP to
do everything in your cells
and contract muscles.
Well, gee, how do you go from
bond energy to actually
contracting things, to actually
doing what we see in
our everyday world as
mechanical energy?
And this is really where
it all occurs.
This is really the core issue
that's going on here.
And you have to say, well, gee,
how this thing change
shape and all that?
And you have to remember,
these proteins, based on
what's bonded to it and
what's not bonded to
it, they change shape.
And some of those shapes take
more energy to attain, and
then if you do the right things,
that energy can be
released and then it can
push another protein.
But I find this just
fascinating.
And now we can build up from
this actin and myosin
interactions to understand how
muscles actually work.